when I decided to do an episode on the
classic Nicktoons cat dog one question
stood out as the hardest one to answer
should I be using dog memes or cat memes
pun dog or hover cat dancing dog vine or
dancing cat vine how can you choose you
know what I am hacking bamboozle to play
me off keyboard cat
[Music]
hello internet welcome to Phil theory
the show that makes videos out of all
those weird thoughts that keep you up at
night like this one
you know keyboard cat is a cat that
plays the piano well what would happen
if he made a piano that was made out of
cats sounds ridiculous well don't let
humanity hear you talking like that
because wonder no longer internet it
already exists it's called the cat
synclavier it was imagined though never
actually made by a German scholar back
in 1650 1650 that's right loyal
theorists cat pianos predate electricity
I'm glad that scholars were working on
the questions that truly mattered back
then but anyway we're here to talk today
about a big part of my childhood that
I'm pretty shocked I haven't actually
done an episode on yet Nicktoons gather
around the fire youngins because old dad
pat is here to tell you of a time before
cell phones and the internet when the
greatest joy of the weekend was waking
up on a Saturday morning eating half
your body weight and Cap'n Crunch with
crunch berries thank you very much and
turning on nickelodeon for a full slate
of Nicktoons hosted by a popsicle stick
with googly eyes forget your fancy
youtube Flash animators all you Jayden's
and Rebekah's and dom mixes demux i we
had ourselves a stick his name was stick
stick ly and we loved him he had a P o
box that rhymed with his name stick
stick ly P o box 963 New York City New
York State 101 o8 he taught me that I
could pick a rose pick my nose and oh
yeah I could also pick Nickelodeon's
shows yeah they burned those rhymes into
your head as a kid back then
I am indoctrinated anyway I loved the
Nicktoons and I related to all the
characters in him I lived in a dream
world and imagined myself as a superhero
like Doug you know my superhero didn't
wear underwear on his head because you
know that's a little showy no one wants
to see those tighty whities I was the
stick-in-the-mud only child who never
wanted to get into trouble like Chucky
from Rugrats so let's be honest with
ourselves here in retrospect Tommy
pickles was a menace who was a threat to
all those other babies and honestly to
his parents and I was tormented by other
kids at school like
Goldin hey arnold go I wasn't teased
because my head was shaped like a
football it was just because I was a
dork but what are the Nicktoons that
always fascinated me the most at least
on a theorist sorta level was CatDog the
show if you haven't seen it is pretty
straightforward you've got yourself an
animal with a cat's head on one side and
a dog's head on the other side and a
long shared body in between like a big
wobbly hot dog cat is a refined
intellectual and dog is well he's a dog
Oh high jinks ensue it's funny it's
weird and it got me wondering all these
years later is a cat dog creature
possible now maybe I'm crazy for
thinking this I mean it is a kids
cartoon for crying out loud but think
about it this way cat dog premiered back
in 1998 and since then we've had a few
massive scientific breakthroughs from
hybrid cars to the Human Genome Project
to discovering water on Mars I mean just
the other day I learned from a friend
that you can clone your dog for like
twenty thousand dollars if that sounds
like a lot remember you are literally
creating a genetic duplicate of a living
creature with scientific technology that
was only perfected in 1995 I wonder if I
can clone skip that would be weird
youtuber merch you can have a skip of
your very own save that one for the
Holiday Collection anyway as far as I'm
concerned the only thing stopping cat
dog from becoming a reality is the
limitation of our own imagination so
today we're gonna play a little dr.
Frankenstein to see just what it would
take to make a cat dog it would
literally be the perfect pet yep man's
best friend crossed with man's most
ambivalent friend mix the two together
and you get like man's most pleasant
next-door neighbor now this episode is
all about the scientific possibility of
creating a cat dog but I realized that
that starts us off with a pretty big
assumption that a cat dog doesn't
already exist do a quick google search
and you'll find that yeah scientists
have apparently successfully already
bred a cat dog well that was fast good
show everybody see you next week
but hey of course then you notice that
the scholarly site you're getting this
information from is called hat stir com
you can't find any record online of the
scientists mentioned in their news
Nicolle quote-unquote and you realize
that the picture of the cat dog hybrid
looks like it was made in Microsoft
Paint fake news is everywhere these days
but there is something here worth
mentioning which is that rumors of cat
dogs go way back long before janky blog
sites a report in the French publication
lamaa Cargill all puts the earliest
recorded instance of cat dog
hybridization in 1698 there were other
well-publicized incidents from the 1930s
and 1970s in which people claimed to
have cross bred or discovered animals
that were part cat and part dog now of
course all of these were eventually shot
down as hoaxes made by people look and
make a quick buck speaking of people who
lie to you to steal your money it's
worth mentioning PT Barnum here
yeah the circus guy oh sure we all know
him as the guy who just had that mad
movie musical man after him and us
hardcore musical theater nerds know him
as the guy who also has a mass stage
musical made after him but it's
important to remember that this is a guy
who got famous for doing things like
sewing a salmon tail to a monkey
skeleton to claim that he had found
himself a mermaid clickbait is
everywhere ladies and gentlemen all
throughout history anyway my point is
that the world's been begging for cat
dogs for centuries there's clearly a
market for it PT Barnum and the other
swindlers weren't able to do it despite
what they were claiming otherwise so
it's my turn to step up to the plate and
give the people what they want the copy
it's a cross between kitten puppy it
actually it sounds more like a cross
between kittens and Guppies the Kippy
most logical way to create a cat dog it
would seem would be by mating a cat with
a dog thereby creating a hybrid creature
that contains traits of both animals
after all that's how we get animals like
mules ligers and wall pins which are
combo whale dolphins and yeah all three
of those things are real I mean it's not
like you were questioning that mules
were real but ligers and ball pins yeah
I'm like whoa those are real and yes yes
they are that's one that they don't
teach you in kindergarten
B is for vulture W is for what the heck
is that frickin nature just when you
thought you knew the animal kingdom am i
right a big part of the reason these
cross breeds exist is that the animal
parents are genetically similar enough
to make a viable offspring which we can
demonstrate using a little bit of tech
sauna me now you may remember that
science classifies animals in a variety
of different categories which are
kingdom phylum class order family genus
species from
be specific to most specific if you
can't remember that just remember Kanye
prefers coke over flat grape soda
because of course he does flat grape
soda is gross so consider that to make a
mule you need a donkey and a horse which
belonged to the same kingdom phylum
class order family and genus only their
species is different with donkeys
belonging to equus africanus asinus and
horses belonging to Equus ferus caballus
in the evolutionary scheme of things
horses and donkeys didn't become
different animals until very recently
about four to four and a half million
years ago cats and dogs on the other
hand are as different as well cats and
dogs they're not nearly as similar
biologically considering they only share
kingdom phylum class and order then
separate into the families Philly de for
cats and candy de for dogs then further
separate out from there the common
ancestors for cats and dogs existed
around 70 million years ago meaning that
cat and dog DNA have had that much more
time to become different and less
compatible most hybrid animals breed
across species and very occasionally
across genus and very very very rarely
across family or even order so from that
very theoretical stance a cat dog hybrid
would be feasible but mathematically
it's just not gonna happen and create a
viable creature further adding to the
complications is that cats and dogs have
a different number of chromosomes those
little bundles of DNA that mix together
when we create offspring now I just use
mules as an example and yeah donkeys and
horses also don't have the same number
of chromosomes donkeys have 62 and
horses have 64 so mules have 63 extra
chromosome there isn't gonna rock the
boat too much though it should be said
that the odd number of chromosomes here
means that except in extremely rare
cases mules are gonna end up infertile
but now let's look at our hypothetical
cat dog hybrid here we're not talking
about a two chromosome difference we're
talking about a 40 chromosome difference
cats have 38 chromosomes and dogs have
78 here's the scientific facts that also
qualifies as a fun fact
King crabs have themselves over 200
chromosomes go figure
what exactly would happen to this 58
chromosomes hybrid is purely theoretical
though when you consider that damage to
even a single chromosome in human DNA
tends to create a lot of health problems
it's unlikely that a CatDog created this
way would have any chance of creating a
viable creature let alone surviving
being born
all right so even though we can't create
a CatDog the old-fashioned way that
doesn't necessarily mean we're sunk yet
a number of the show's fans note that
cat dogs home town near burg is a bit of
a desolate barren wasteland with no
people and only talking animals and
whatever Winslow here is they have
therefore theorized that it may be a
sort of post apocalyptic radioactive
wasteland if so maybe cat dog is a
mutant and then all we need to do to
create our own is find ourselves a leaky
nuclear reactor history tells us that
yea high levels of radiation tends to
mess with plants and animals in the
surrounding area in the aftermath of the
Chernobyl meltdown local wildlife
experienced a number of different
mutations mutations that I'm about to
show you and that if you don't want to
see now might be a good time to take a
15 second vacation down in the comments
say hi to everyone else down there who
doesn't want to use eye bleach today
make yourselves a new friend
everyone scroll down who wanted to
scroll down fantastic so in addition to
animals that were smaller thinner or
misshapen in the wake of this disaster
you also got yourself some really crazy
results in particular animals that had
extra body parts like just lamb with
eight legs and to get a little bit more
on-brand with cat dog this donkey with
two heads genetics and radiation man it
gets weird reminds me of that episode of
Bob's Burgers with a goat who has two
months anyway all right comment crew you
can come on back up now so based on what
some of you just saw it would seem like
we have proof that radiation can create
a two-headed animal like cat dog right
well no again and to understand why we
have to get into the science of how
these mutations work you see high levels
of radiation tend to damage cellular DNA
this isn't necessarily a problem because
DNA has mechanisms to repair itself but
those repairs aren't always exactly
right it's like taking a shirt to the
dry cleaners to sew a button back on
most of the time they sew the button
back on perfectly which would be a
metaphor for DNA successfully repairing
itself sometimes they sewed a button on
but it's slightly
too high or slightly too low which would
be an imperfect but still functional
repair and then sometimes instead of
sewing the button back on the shirt they
like the shirt on fire and cover it in
thumbtacks and that's how you end up
with an eight-legged spider sheet at any
rate these mutations can definitely lead
to some strange results but they're not
random you might get the doubling of
certain genes that create legs or even
heads but you wouldn't get an organism
with a separate head far away from the
first head besides all of the mutations
that you're gonna see affect a single
organism and to create an animal like
cat dog you're somehow gonna have to
splice the cat DNA with a dog DNA which
radiation and subsequent mutations
simply can't do on their own so it
strike two for our mad science
experiment which leads us to our third
and most desperate option and it's a
dark one so buckle up let's say you're a
mad scientist who just can't live in a
world without cat dogs and knowing that
you can't interbreed cats and dogs or
use radiation to create a mutant cat dog
you decide to take things into your own
hands Human Centipede style by
surgically creating a cat dog if you are
somehow able to perform the surgery so
well that you could merge the two spines
and internal organs such that the
surgery itself was a structural success
would this cat dog be able to live well
you know how when someone needs an organ
transplant you have to do tests to make
sure that the possible donor is a match
this matching system has to do with
similarities in the blood and tissues
between the donor and the recipient
the more differences there are in those
tissues the more likely the body's
immune system is gonna recognize that
organ is foreign which leads to the
immune system attacking it as though it
was bacteria or a virus in order to kill
it and cats and dogs like I've mentioned
are genetically different so it makes
sense that they would reject each other
but that's not the case though it
happens only in very rare cases cats
that have received a single blood
transfusion from a dog usually live
interestingly enough cats that receive
multiple transfusions tend to reject the
blood the second time which suggests
that after an initial transfusion the
cat's body just recognizes it as
different from its own blood it's a
weird little phenomenon but yeah on the
cat's side it is perfectly viable dogs
on the other hand have a very difficult
time receiving organ donations at all
cats or otherwise because the canine
immune system tends to attack any
tissues that aren't
direct relatives a dog's immune system
literally acts just like a dog it's
overeager it barks at everything it's
adorable to think about until you
consider that it makes biological
treatment of sick dogs really really
hard and then it becomes really sad
anyway for the first time ever it's not
the cat's fault the cat's immune system
would potentially allow it to happen
it's the dog that would make this
impossible surgery even more impossible
and that leaves us with um no
crossbreeding no nuclear fallout not
even mad science is gonna create a cat
dog at the end of the day we're just
stuck with the glory that is dog O's and
flutes so I ask again what's that leave
us with the cartoon I guess which
honestly ain't too shabby and making it
even better is that lucky for us cat dog
and a bunch of other Nicktoons are
available for you to watch right now on
Verve oh yeah if you have a craving to
revisit the simpler times of your
childhood or honestly if you're too
young and missed out on some of the best
shows to ever air on television ever
verve has all sorts of must-see NIC
splat shows dog real monsters Nick
arcade where you actually go into a
video game and shows that you won't
believe that they actually showed the
kids back in the 90s like Rocko's Modern
Life seriously if you have never seen
Rocko's Modern Life just watch it and
remember this was meant to be a show for
kids in fact if you watch it come back
to this video and let me know what you
thought about it because whoo boy times
have changed
what is acceptable for kids to watch has
changed then Verve also has incredible
nostalgic game shows like double dare mm
global guts where spoiler alert the
purple team never wins and what is to
this day still on my bucket list of life
running through a game of legends of the
Hidden Temple to pin it down in the
comments were you a red jaguar purple
parrot blue Barracuda or silver snake if
you are an orange iguana or a green
monkey you need not apply if you're
eager for even more nostalgia they also
have freakazoid and Thundercats all of
this and more courtesy of Verve where
you can get a 30-day free trial of Verve
premium you heard that right free a
Verve premium which gives you ad free
access to 13 channels including
crunchyroll Funimation and cartoon
hangover
because seriously why would you not want
to follow up an angry beavers binge with
Dragon Ball super and my hero akka all
in premium HD all of it is available on
verb get that 30 day free trial of Verve
premium which includes all those shows
and the ability to watch on the go with
no internet connection by going to Verve
dotco
slash Matt hat that's a VR veto /m ATP
80 seriously guys get yourself some nick
nick nick nick nick nick nick
nickelodeon only now in the modern age
in the convenience of your pocket or
computer or TV or pretty much any other
digital device where you want to watch
something now play me off keyboard cat
and remember that's just a theory film
theory and cuts